on va rentrer à pied au domaine tu fais
rouler je te le porte tu le mets sur ton
dos au cœur de la selogne
viticol le domaine d'Isabelle Pango est
à seulement quelques mètres du bourg de
[Musique]
sassuation à 40 ans la jeune vigneronne
est aussi une jeune mère de famille j'ai
besoin de de me dire que je suis pas en
train de passer à côté d'un des pan de
ma vie que ce soit mon le pan
professionnel ou le P
familial pour moi ça fait c'est un tout
et je veux je veux tout je veux tout
concilier
elle est à la tête du domaine de l'affu
14 hectares de cespage blanc et rouge
vinifié sur
place au début je me suis installé seule
parce que bah j'étais salarié avant donc
l'idée c'était de pouvoir faire les
choses qui me ressemble ble assez
personnel d'avoir une dimension de
création aussi sur le domaine donc
c'était important pour ça d'être assez
libre mais aujourd'hui après 5 ans
d'activité à mener de front toutes les
différentes parties du métier de de
vigneron je vois aussi le le prix de la
solitude
coucou ça va
h c'est passé oui c'est un projet
personnel mais partagé en famille
Mathieu son conjoint ne travaille pas
dans le vin mais il l'aide sur la partie
stratégie marketing et communication ça
je le mettrai en annexe on a dit ça s et
en fait ça je feris plutôt des verbtim
elle gère en fait la barque toute seule
celle qui aelle dit la légitimité
technique en fait sur ce métier de de la
seule chose que je peux lui apporter
effectivement c'est parfois un peu ce
pas de côté parce que quand on a la tête
dans le guidon comme elle le dit c'est
pas toujours
[Musique]
évident 70 km plus au sud le domaine
Claude Laffond est une référence dans
l'appellation
re 35 hectar salariés permanents et une
trentaine de saisonniers pour les
vendanges gérante de l'exploitation
créée par son grand-père Nathalie Lafond
a aussi hérité de la passion de la vigne
et d'une sacré force de caractère oui B
on n pas envie d'aller à la salle de
sport après à la fin de la journée on en
a pas besoin après c'est physique c'est
surtout c'est sur la durée voilà on cap
c'est vraiment sur la durée où on
piétine beaucoup on monte on descend je
pense qu'on fait des kilomètres dans une
journée la vigneronne de 43 ans est
partout mais elle prend toujours le
temps quand un client arrive à
l'improviste donc là on sent que ça
pétit donc les levures sont en action
elles commencent à dégrader les sucres
pour les transformer en alcool le vin
est un partage ça c'est une certitude
pour moi mais en plus moi je fais des
vins mais c'est bien de savoir ce que le
client il en pense et c'est important
d'écouter c'est important de de de
partager avec les gens qui viennent au
domaine pour goûter ce qu'ils en pensent
quel style de vin ils apprécient et là
c'est vrai qu'on voit depuis depuis
plusieurs années il y a il y a une
évolution aussi sur le goût de notre
clientèle la clientèle est fidèle et
après de générations de Vigner la
dynastie des Lafond se
féminise vigneron vigneron pour moi ça
reste quelqu'un qui produit du vin et ce
qui me paraître l'élément le plus
important c'est que il y ait de l'amour
du travail bien fait et puis la
transparence
aussi je crois que c'est vraiment
important aujourd'hui parce que boire du
vin c'est pas un acte isolé c'est aussi
important de savoir quelle est la
philosophie du vigron la manière dont il
travaille et puis ce qu'il a réellement
envie de faire de son
vin
[Musique]
ce Chinon est servi sur la table du
George 5 à Paris quelques bouteilles
heureusement restent dans la ville de
Rabelais ce caviste est fier de
travailler avec Fiona
Beston je l'ai laissé en fu 2 ans c'est
la première fois que je fais ça et je
pense que ça l'a permis de
se de se poser un
peu cette fille de britannique a 68 ans
elle élève ses deux cuvets rouges depuis
2010 c'est quelqu'un de toujours très
dynamique qui a su s'imposer à Chinon
quand même c'est pas facile dans un
milieu qui était historiquement masculin
et surtout surtout ici et elle a su
s'imposer de par sa sa sincér vité je je
pense le Clos des Capucins en 1604
c'était un monastère trois petites
parcelles de vignes font face à la
forteresse de chinan ça a été le coup de
foudre qui s'est fait attendre
évidemment j'étais complètement branché
Chinon j'ai pas voulu faire autre chose
que Chinon donc je descendais toutes les
semaines à la recherche j'étais à
l'hôtel et cetera 3 ans ça m'a pris et à
la fin mes copines m'ont dit
tu as essayé le golf enfin plus personne
me prenait au sérieux quand j'ai vu cet
endroit j'ai dit bon bah c'est là où je
c'est là où je veux passer le reste de
ma vie et si je peux pas l'avoir et ben
je quitte la France ancienne caviste
chez Lucien le grandrand à Paris Fiona
Beston a été 20 ans journaliste à La
Revue du vin de France avant de sauter
le
pas j'avais vraiment envie de de plutôt
que de critiquer le vin parce que
j'étais assez ferme comme critique assez
craint je dois dire et finalement quand
je suis devenue vigneron je me suis
rendue compte qu'on fait un
maximum pour on peut tout faire quoi
bien
des va travailler le sol enfin tout et
en fait on est à la merci de de la
nature alors là c'est un peu plus
délicat dans le loirch
à côté des baries classiques Isabelle
Pango revisite aussi l'utilisation des
jar en terre cuite ah oui c'est sympa
c'est un
spa un spa au raisin
gratuit l'ingénieur agronome mélange
tradition et nouvelles pratiques elle
veut dépoussiierer le métier c'est juste
un petit foulage au pied de quelques
raisins pour faire suffisamment de J J
pour faire des remontages ensuite
c'està-dire pomper du jus d'en bas et
asperger sur le dessus mais j'essaie de
garder au maximum des grappes entières
pour faire des arômes très
fruités logique de travailler avec le
chef Stéphane buau qui s'est installé
dans la région en même temps que la
Vigner ronne à contre à 3 km du
[Musique]
Domaine
son vin commeelle en fait j'ai trouvé
qu'il y avait une une certaine fraîcheur
en fait et une détermination de ce
qu'elle veut faire de ce qu'elle veut
bien faire et et ça se ressent en fait
ça se ressent sur sur les étiquettes sur
le sur sur le vin sur la vinification
sur le travail qu' y apporte non non je
trouve que juste il y a il y a quelque
chose d'extrêmement réfléchi
làdedans avec des produits locaux le
restaurateur a imaginé une recette pour
accompagner la cuvé en ambivalente un
assemblage de deux spages
blancs le plat nous transforme la
sensation qu'on a du vin et ça nous fait
découvrir un nouveau visage de nos de
vin ne serait-ce que le fait qu'il soit
servi dans un autre verre que ceux avec
lequel on goûte d'habitude on découvre
un nouveau visage de no de vin et quand
il est associé à un plat qu'on a jamais
goûté c'est encore une nouvelle facette
qu'on découvre donc c'est toujours
vraiment un vrai plaisir
ou en ber l'AOP re monte
la famille Laffond y contribue 3
hectares et demi en
1977 10 fois plus aujourd'hui Nathalie
veille sur le patrimoine et le fait
fructifier moi c'est une très grande
fierté aujourd'hui de ce qui a été fait
par mon grand-père et par mon père
clairement l'appellation en est là
aujourd'hui parce que il a eu envie il
s'est énormément investi et moi cet
investissement là je trouve ça fabuleux
par contre mes choix j'avance et sans me
poser la question de me dire est-ce que
c'est ce que Claude aurait fait ouais je
me pose pas du tout cette question là
j'ai une équipe on met des choses en
place on on avance on avance est-ce que
aujourd'hui mon père aurait fait une
conversion bio j'en sais rien il y a 15
ans il était pas pour peut-être
qu'aujourd'hui il l'aurait été je sais
pas et et je me pose pas plus de
questions que ça
là-dessus grand-père père et fille étai
très liés dans le magasin Duchet le
visiteur entre facilement dans
l'intimité de la famille
donc là j'ai retrouvé deux anciennes
photos où on voit mon grand-père André
ma grand-mère Denis sur une foirein à r
traditionnelle foirevin de ri et puis là
c'est ma grand-mère donise jeune
adolescente qui doit avoir je pense une
quinzaine d'années avec les paniers
avendange plein de
raisons Nathalie Lafond est elle aussi
dans la démarche de transmission d'un
nom j'espère si par la suite bah il y a
un repreneur de la famille aussi qui qui
gardera ce nom de domaine Claude Laffond
et après qui lui apportera sa pointe de
personnalité mais c'est vraiment une
volonté de garder le nom de Mar c'est
Claude
[Musique]
la si Fiona Beston a choisi ce domaine
c'est pour ses vignes elles sont
centenire ce sont les plus anciennes sur
chin
j'adore quand ils sont vieux quoi parce
que ils te donneent quelque chose de
beaucoup plus jeunes forcément bon ils
sont jeunes quoi mais les vieux il y a
tout un passé qui ressort quoi les
racines sont allés loin ils ont tout vu
ils ont vécu les guerres ils sont
toujours
là des boutures des vignes ancestrales
sont replantées sur cette autre parcelle
ce sera long pour récolter le nectar
mais qu'importe comme elle le dit
joliment Fiona a abandonné d'être pressé
faut attendre peut-être 5 ans et ça va
être des jeunes grappes donc ça va être
bon ils sont tout fou on n pas de
profondeur et ce sera pour mes enfants
ou mes petits enfants 50 ans
quoi le jardin secret de Fiona Beston a
été creusé dans la pierre de tufo au 16e
siècle ici le vin peut
méditer cette est vraiment assez unique
parce qu'elle est en forme de fer de
cheval donc il y a une très belle
aération mais en même temps c'est très
intime quand on travaille dehors dans la
vigne on est pris par le vent le le
soleil la pluie la boue et des fois je
prends un verre ici seul ça me va très
[Musique]
bien
je me suis dit un hectare je serai là
lundi mardi puis le reste du temps je
remonte à Paris parce que mon mari est à
Paris en fait je suis là tout le temps
maintenant et consentente j'adore être
ici quoi c'est un endroit
extraordinaire ouais c'est mes vraies
[Musique]
racines tris parcours différents TR vies
façons de travailler différentes mais
désormais les mêmes racines cell du
terroir du centre
Loire une passion commune la vigne un
destin commun celui de donner du
plaisir